welcome back to new rockstars this is
the b question the show that gives you
too much information on who the toughest
meanest most nefarious mobster is in the
big apple and no we do not mean the
creepy times square elmo but he is
definitely certainly up there don't yeah
don't let your kids near that thing it's
free oh no it just feels very very
creepy probably has lots of sicknesses i
don't know sorry i shouldn't talk about
about a person cut that out my name
is mt and i'm here today of course with
my brother off screen
brandon what's going on brandon hello mt
so happy to be here today uh great to be
back on big question with you and i'm
very excited
for what we're gonna talk about new
series baby new series new series
hawkeye hey haley steinfeld season's in
baby
it's the reason for the season it's why
it's why everyone gives each other gifts
around this time of year oh is that why
it's that one yeah it's not because our
lord jesus christ was born come on empty
come on you better watch your mouth
they're gonna leave he's gonna get
canceled anyway hit me with that big
question brandon okay mt so as we're
saying we got a new show on disney plus
hawkeye it's finally out we got the
first two episodes what uh what a
thanksgiving miracle it was to get two
fresh episodes right next to my stuffing
and my mashed potatoes and gravy
delicious um
but uh what i really like about this
show is that you know it's it's focusing
on just kind of a little incident in new
york city it's not a world-ending event
we don't got giant space gods being born
out of the earth we don't got holes
opening up in timelines you know this is
just like a little kind of world ending
for some people like clint's family i
mean okay well if one family's gotta get
their christmas ruined i think that's
okay okay so be it
so be it if one christmas one family
gets a bad christmas i'm so sorry
so we have this like this threat this
new threats in new york city it's a
little some crime syndicates some mobs
going on the secret ingredient is crime
that all leads us to this week's big
question mt when it comes to organized
crime in new york city who's the boss
who's the big boss who's the boss
yeah we gotta make it's time to make
like tony danza and figure out just who
is right the boss because marvel comics
are full of nefarious gangs and crime
syndicates working their way through the
grimy streets of new york city and with
the new hawkeye series in full swing
we're finally going to get a look at
some of these groups now being
officially inside of the mcu which is
really great so we see you netflix
series well we'll get to that we'll get
to that but let's start off with the
first group that we've officially been
introduced to in this series and bro i
know you know what i'm talking about bro
it's going to be the tracksuit mafia bro
come on bro my favorite gang
the number one gang in the mc in marvel
comics i'm glad they're here um they uh
rival hydra in my opinion um they're
dealing with some difficult issues i
appreciate the honesty of the tracksuit
mafia right
it's tough to find a good warehouse
these days they're all exactly
gentrification is ruining everything
it's true and as a kid who went to a
christian private school from grade five
to 12.
uniforms are really great at uh uniting
a group of people and uh just killing
all creativity and individuality just
completely is great for that i mean it's
great you know
a lot of times these gangs in comics
they go a little overboard you know
with the joker all of his men always
have to have like face paint on his
stuff no just get like a nice outfit
that you can all buy you can get it in
your size it's great it's comfortable
it's functional it's got pockets i mean
what a great what a great uniform i mean
like shades was wearing the shades all
the time and luke cage was like bro
we're indoors what are you doing yeah
that's not smart the tracksuit mafia
also known as the tracksuit draculas in
the matt fractured hawkeye comics this
series is taking inspiration from are a
group of enforcers with vaguely eastern
european origins and it's clear to see
that these guys are pretty low level
since they're the only ones getting
their answer and it's really interesting
to know that in the secret auction scene
in the first episode the auctioneer says
now you may recall the ronin decimated
the criminal underworld of this city
almost completely annihilating the
status and power of the head of
organized crime and so that puts the
series in a really interesting situation
where older embedded nyc crime groups
may have been completely wiped out
leading to a power vacuum and the
tracksuit mafia might be the only
low-level gang in town at the moment or
at least the most you know competent
low-level one i may be an idiot
but i'm not stupid and we should also
point out that when clint is talking to
laura about these guys he says at least
until i
clear things up at the old track suit
friends
jesus not those idiots
those idiots i'm not sure how it goes up
so and like we said they're clearly not
at the very top of the food chain and
there's plenty of room to go up from
them and in fact we already saw one
person that they're working for and that
is miss echo and they seem kind of
afraid of her they're like um
sorry to interrupt this uh the super
loud stuff that you're
feeling listening to i don't know how
your powers work bro but uh yeah we got
a guy uh we got him yeah i mean i guess
she does have to feel it huh uh yeah i
do i really like the tracksuit mafia the
track suit dracus i guess we're calling
him the tracksuit mafia in this one you
love to see the unity they have you love
to see how they all work together they
support each other
you know it is fun but they're clearly
not the head of
whatever's going on in new york you know
these guys are just enforcers right they
got to do the dirty work um but that
point you bring up about ronan is very
interesting because you know we had this
situation where ronan's running around
for five years wiping out organized
crime that i'm sure was definitely
rising up during during the blip or
during the snap so it is cool to think
that like he might have like kind of
cleaned the slate in new york city right
he wiped out a lot of the bad gangs uh
and now someone is moving in to take
over or took over in the absence of all
other gangs yeah it's really interesting
to see what's going on with those mafia
guys and i have this weird feeling that
the tracksuit mafia could be sokovian
and bro i know you know what i'm talking
about bro it's going to be the tracksuit
mafia bro like oh we don't really know
where they are in the comments like it's
always vague in the comics so like with
this more emphasis being given on
sokovia in both juan division and in
fact in the winter soldier it just seems
that sokovia has more of a role to play
in the mcu so it makes sense to make the
track suit sokovian linked i mean i
imagine at least one or two of them are
from sokovia right they could be all
over they could be from all over eastern
europe you know you come to new york you
know you try and get a job at
baskin-robbins it's impossible because
they're always looking at your criminal
history so you gotta enjoy i always find
out they always find out they always
find out so you gotta join the tracksuit
mafia because you know they welcome all
people all shapes and sizes as long as
you fit into a track suit
i do also appreciate that clint's very
upfront with laura about what he's doing
and she knows what's been going on he's
not keeping things from her she's always
uh in the know you know what i like when
he says he's gonna pull the
uh uh what'd he say get caught i think
he said get help he's gonna do a get
help
you got help please my brother he's
dying get help help him
and laura i need your help we need to
get help i need you i need you here
uh
but yeah he's doing a little catcher
release and she's like that's natasha's
old move rap natasha uh we'll never
forget you but yeah i do like the
relationship they have all of these
honestly he's like listen i gotta deal
with this problem you know since i i i
was running and i killed a bunch of bad
guys and now there's a power vacuum uh
i'm gonna fix this problem whoops
oops hey man that's a ride or die wife
he's like hey i can tell you about that
time i killed a bunch of people you're
just like it's fine you were going
through stuff i was dead it's totally
fine it's totally fine you know
you know you got to do what you got to
do i'm not going to give you a hard time
about it the last thing i'll say about
the trucks and mafia is like in in terms
of their link to possibly sokovia is
that they do have the the purple
mass right like zemo he did kind of have
like yeah yeah it was hard to tell the
exact color but i got sort of zemo vibes
from that i'm like i mean obviously
zemo doesn't have the freaking monopoly
on purple masks anyone can wear a purple
ski mask but i'm just saying like that'd
be an interesting thing like ah we all
are linked with zemo a little bit who
knows oh that'd be fun maybe they really
like him they want to support him right
it's like we just think he's really cool
you know he took down the avengers guy
bruh that's a cool guy but yes maya
lopez aka echo is a native american with
the ability of photographic reflexes
this means that she is capable of
perfectly reproducing the physical
movements and actions of anyone that she
observes and she also happens to be deaf
and we first see her at the end of
episode 2 but it's clear that she's
going to be a really big presence in the
series and it appears that she is going
to be the one giving orders to the
tracksuit mafia so it's clear that she
is above them on the nyc crime food
chain but is she the main boss
probably not one interesting thing to
note from the comics at one point echo
dons the ronin suit and takes on the
persona and we saw what a big role that
infamous ninja suit has played in the
series so far so could we see echo
become ronan by the end of this series i
think there's a possibility there that
would be really interesting i mean it
was it was kind of fascinating how like
important the ninja suit was the fact
that i kept calling it just
kind of
i loved seeing grylls wearing it oh my
god
i was like bro this is how you die
grills why why
sorry
that was great but yeah it's they're
really like putting a lot of emphasis on
like the importance of this suit it's
like the physical representation of
clint's shame and everything yeah it
would be really cool if she took on she
became like the new ronin and ronan kind
of sticks around for a little bit i mean
she could just be echo echo's a good
enough name she doesn't need to take
another name i think anyone wearing that
suit would just be badass so they should
just always be a ronin around like that
there's always a captain america that
should always just be around and just
yeah i'll just be a fighting crime like
well and without like the real
taskmaster because i don't know
you know post the events of black widow
if taskmaster can still do the
taskmaster thing without the chip or the
gas i don't know but uh she echoes the
real deal she's got the ability so
uh oh yeah and like i i mentioned this
to eric um during our inside marvel i
think the way that she was introduced
was might have been purposeful because
she was in a red room they introduced
her in a red room so like what if she's
linked to the red room and she went
underwent the same types of um you know
experiments that the taskmaster went
through i think that
could be uh marvel's way of just being
like all right here's more uh
photographic reflex people and in the
comics maya's dad is killed by wilson
fisk who we all known as kingpin and she
winds up working for fisk as he's
obviously very impressed with her skills
i would want her to work for me
sorry i killed your dad please come work
for me you're really cool
my bad oopsies i could make it up to you
with money and gainful employment
sorry
could this mean that we're going to see
some kingpin in this series brandon
could it be could it be true please let
it because cross vincent d'onofrio would
not mind i don't think even though this
series is already done you can just
sneak it in and focus
put them on a green literally just put
them in there have vincent on his camera
phone just be like it's and it's me
and me don't forget about me
as the post-credits seated like and me
i'm here goodbye
in episode one when kate is listening in
on eleanor's conversation with armand
she hears armand say don't you try that
on me i gave you an opportunity
i have powerful friends too
and sure armond could be talking about
echo but a rich and influential guy like
armand probably has even more powerful
friends so yes let's talk about the
elephant-sized man in the room mr
kingpin himself because it's a huge
possibility kingpin is in fact the
undisputed boss of crime in new york
city i don't know if you've ever seen a
spider-man i don't know if you ever
played spider-man ps4 i don't know if
you've ever just seen kingpin in the
spider-man animated series from the 90s
that man is in charge period and he was
originally introduced in the comics as a
foil to spider-man um as you can see
clearly the opposite of spider is wide
many spiders are killed by wide shoes
killed objects
so uh you know it's a very smart choice
a spiders fear
why
but of course he quickly crossed over to
mess with any hero that dare step a toe
into his business in nyc how dare you
how dare you how dare you the invisible
hand is actually just kingpin with his
huge giant strong hand
and or possibly the hand the
organization
but we don't talk about them
or else like kill us all now we have
seen kingpin represented in an mcu
adjacent property and this of course
being michael clark duncan's portrayal
in the 2003 film daredevil starring ben
affleck the best uh daredevil
uh adaptation there is uh netflix full
stop
this one this is the you know
you can hate on the 2003 daredevil and
that's fine you're you're certainly
allowed to do that but mcd you know he
held it down in that one he really did
mcd michael darkin's kingpin was
fantastic everything else about that
movie is pretty
tough
[Music]
the kingpin rules in that movie while
iconic it's probably not the one that
you're thinking of but more recently
kingpin was played by of course vincent
d'onofrio from the much loved daredevil
series on netflix and rumors are
swirling about that that same kingpin
may be making his way over to the mcu
officially and maybe even charlie cox's
daredevil as well maybe maybe please
kevin please let like happen kevin
please kevin feige one above i know i
asked you for a live stream that's
charlotte cox oh i'm asking you exactly
we need vincent d'onofrio i would also
take kaylee steinfeld's kingpin okay
here we go again here we go again
she would look good in the white suit
she would look better
we got to see vicky d come back
bring him back
vinnie d was amazing as kingpin and i i
literally cannot think of anyone else
that is kingpin he's literally kingpin i
know the people would go crazy if if
they put anyone else in that world i
would not want to be the actor that has
to like take that role right now he sort
of has that like wolverine factor like
yeah whoever's going to take over for
hugh jackman is going to be though he's
going to have a really bad couple months
yeah but daily stay at least like
sunsetted that character i mean poor
poor vinnie d they just put him in jail
and you're like come on he's still right
there just bring him out bring him out
it really does seem that kingpin would
be the perfect ultimate baddie to be
revealed as the boss of the new york
city crime world but the inclusion of
echo in this series and the fact that it
was announced on disney plus day that
there will be an echo spin-off series
means that kingpin's appearance in the
mcu is pretty much a foregone conclusion
but there are some other crime bosses
out there that we should consider
including one that we just met very
recently the power broker sharon carter
killed um batroc just in cold blood i
can't even believe it just because steve
rogers broke your heart don't do crime
don't do a crime
i want a list of all steve rogers
ex-girlfriends or the peoples that he's
they're out of romantic things with and
see how many of them have become super
villains
[Music]
but then again chris evans is very
handsome so i would probably act up too
if you broke up with me i don't blame
you sharon carter aka the power broker
could be revealed to be the ultimate
boss of the hawkeye series and we know
that this show is taking place after the
events of falco the winner soldier
throughout girl seren carter is back on
american soil at this point so that
means that the power broker is here too
not that the power broker couldn't have
run her business remotely but it's
probably easier to have secretive
insecure meetings face to face rather
than you know over zoom you know it does
seem like they're setting up kingpin to
be the big boss here but that's a good
point empty you know the power broker's
back in the u.s she's here
she could be doing things she's got
government contracts now so it would
make sense for marvel to have set this
up by having like you know introducing
sharon carter as the power broker and
their one of their more recent series
and then now you have like
obviously some someone's in charge here
it could be the power broker it would be
interesting and it would be a cool thing
for her to get involved in but i don't
know
it seems yeah maybe maybe not it seems
like they're saving her for like armor
wars or something like that or secret
invasion having the power broker on u.s
soil is a huge game changer for a lot of
things because you know she is going to
be moving around a lot of products a lot
of like secret weapons and like a lot of
you know like you mentioned armor wars
is probably going to center a lot around
whatever sharon carter is doing because
there's no greater weapon than an iron
man suit of armor on this planet right
now oh and we still don't know what this
mysterious watch is that whoever
organized exactly the break-in at the
auction wanted so like it could be a
weapon that she wants who knows and of
course we should also consider the ten
rings because the post-credits scene
from shangshi showed us that xia ling
chung chi's sister has taken over the
long-running criminal organization
hiding in the shadows from her father
wenwoo who treated her like so good
for her and she's making some changes if
the series is taking place post shanghi
it could be that the ten rings are at
the top of the food chain in new york
city and even if they're not taking a
visible lead on the front they could
still be the ones pulling the strings in
the shadows and we have to assume that
the 10 rings has some sort of presence
in nyc already because it's a mature hub
in the united states for most businesses
especially in the financial center even
if the ten rings have no presence in the
series they're probably there in the
shadows anyway moving mysteriously and
in episode two when kate has her fencing
showdown with jack he says to eleanor
it's not the first time someone has
tried to take my head off i mean what a
flex what a flex right you know i love
you you're engaged to a new woman and
she's got she's got a kid already and
this is fine and the kids they're not
home it's not like you got to be there
to be a step dad they're off at college
already and then then they show up at
dinner and they try and
fight you
oh you're so good
that's badass that's a badass girl
they're watching i was like oh i was
like wow you all saw sword championships
oh that's so funny
i do this all day
oh champion of your high school huh
well i'm the actual one i'm the actual
swordsman my name's swordsman heard of
it come on given what an accomplished
swordsman the swordsman is anyone that
would want to even try to take his head
off would have to be a skilled fighter
and we know that the ten rings has
plenty of those skilled fighters or
could the threat have come from another
crime group like i don't know the hand
because we've already discussed the
potential for kingpin to be making the
leap from you know the distant netflix
marvel universe to the main mcu because
the hand of course a group of ninjas
operating around the world in the
shadows much like the ten rings do and
in the comics they've been around since
the 1500s and have infiltrated cities
around the world and they even had a
hand in the creation of hydra which is
a pretty shitty hand to uh have a good
fan not something you want a list of
your accomplishments i mean depending on
how you're trying to impress but uh done
a lot of damage it's true a lot of
damage that's a lot of damage
but yes the hand played a prominent role
in the daredevil netflix series but have
not popped up in the mcu you know yet
but it might be just a little bit
complicated to have them show up now
especially you know as they establish
the 10 rings as a very similar type of
organization but they could be easily
brought over from the netflix series and
the mcu could potentially establish that
ronin took them out as part of his you
know gang-killing crusade during those
post-snap five years and given the long
history of the hand it's unlikely that
they were wiped out completely because
you know like we said the hand kind of
hydro vibes you know when you just take
out a little bit of hand just another
finger grows back you know that's how
the hand works like
it's hard to wipe out completely those
demon worshipping cults uh that have
been around for hundreds of years it's
difficult to do you can't you can't get
them all
in one fell swoop you got to hunt them
all down like you kind of said empty
it's like the hand the ten rings they're
kind of very similar right now
in the mcu you know it's like these like
kind of secret shadowy organizations uh
but marvel comics has always been like
that right there's always like
new
uh secret
gangs that pop up that have been around
for hundreds of years that no one
mentioned until this one comic book uh
it's just kind of a thing you have to do
you always have to make up new bad guys
and stuff uh but it would be cool you
know to see them come over if they're
bringing over kingpin and daredevil from
the netflix series does that mean
everything comes over i don't know but
the hand you know showing up now would
be interesting
but i i think it is too soon after kind
of establishing the ten rings as like a
similar organization right well i think
a really fun way that you could do it
because i do like this connection is
that you know ten rings rings go on
hands so like it'd be great rings and
the hands work together because
rings and hands are always meant to go
together so i think it'd be a really fun
connection for them to do that i do like
that one it makes sense that they would
if both of these groups have been
operating the shadows for hundreds of
years they probably met at some point
you know at a bad guy convention or
something and they're like okay let's
exchange crime foundation yeah yeah
crime con
we'll exchange information you know
let's talk you know like hey hey what a
you know should we you know what about
the black plague should we play a role
in that no no yes no i don't know but
yeah they've probably worked together
over the years but it would be cool to
see them i love this idea of the rings
on the hand that's that's beautiful
stuff really beautiful stuff thank you
thank you that's what i do but yeah if
they have the hand they might as well
bring over the foot you know what i'm
talking about
let's go let's go if if marvel and
disney are on this crusade to buy things
go ahead and buy the ninja turtles at
this point because i would love to see
the foot in the mcu i mean that would be
crazy at the you know the season finale
of uh hawkeye if it's revealed that
shredder is in charge of everything in
new york no i would poop my pants
brandon i would literally
put a turtle sized
bro i would scream i would literally i i
wouldn't even have to know how it was
even logistically possible because like
you don't have to explain it they don't
have to make it work just do it yep yeah
but no there's actually one more
potential top boss that we should
consider here and this one goes all the
way back to ant-man and the wasp and
that is the mysterious buyer that sonny
burch was working for buying up all that
powerful tech because we don't know to
this day who this person is they refuse
to answer my emails they refuse to just
it's like playing who's that pokemon but
never getting the answer you know it's
just really annoying
who's that powerful buyer of illegal
technology
it's squirtle
[Laughter]
but that mysterious buyer could be the
one at the very top of the nyc crime
scene and maybe it's someone that we've
already mentioned or it could be a new
character entirely yeah the mcu has kind
of introduced this and i feel like they
purposely were very
uh we'll resolve this at some point it's
almost like a sitting in a little glass
box on the wall and they can break the
glass when they need they need a new bad
guy or something and when they
eventually do reveal it i mean it'll be
great and everyone will lose their mind
you ever heard the name
wilson fisk
especially if we see sonny burch again
uh you know love walton goggins would
love to see him come back to the mcu
well the gogs but yeah it could be you
know the mysterious buyer could just be
the power broker it could be kingpin or
they could just make it a whole new bad
guy uh but i like the connection here
because yeah again they're stealing this
like mysterious watch it could be a
piece of powerful technology and it
could be this buyer so yeah i would love
to see that come back and get that paid
off finally i i honestly i feel like the
sunny birch's buyer could be related to
roxanne in some way oh that would also
be very fun yeah you know that roxcar
was in you know loki and roxanne is this
huge energy corporation and quantum
energy is this huge thing so i just feel
like roxanne might even be working with
some of these uh criminal underworld
people could it be
could it be justin hammer pulling the
strings from the shadows
[Music]
hey who knows it's been a while maybe
he's out of prison he only tried to um
blow up stark expo i'll give you like 10
years
yeah yeah you know and then the world
almost ended like twice and now uh right
right right right right right right
right right see him it's come out of the
ground i'm sure they're releasing a few
prisoners for good behavior hey i've
been turned into a cow can i go home
you're excused the existential crisis
every person on earth should be having
every day right
based on i really love
five years is just insane
i'd be done i'd be done when aeroshim
showed up in the sky to those people in
that park in london i can't just imagine
like going home to your wife and being
like
i can't do it anymore i just can't
live anymore bro it's my number one fear
seeing a big face in the sky everyone
knows this man i would literally gotta
go to work the next day you gotta like
answer emails and you're just like
there's giant space gods why am i
dealing with my outlook calendar nothing
would matter nothing would matter i
wouldn't give a about anything i'd
be like yo if i had a shitty boss which
i don't if i worked in an office and i
had a shitty boss just because
i was discovered
you still got a job tomorrow
i would i would literally cuss out my
boss and then leave i'd be like
this like space gods just threatened my
life i'm leaving that is a brief list of
who could be the big boss of new york
city crime but who do you think it could
be behind it all brad and do you think
is actually behind it all uh i let you
know i wanted to be kingpin deep down in
my heart of hearts i really wanted to be
revealed to big kingpin here um but i'll
go to lim i you know i think it could be
the power broker they've kind of done
this little setup they brought her back
to america i love this idea that she
could be revealed to be the big boss at
the end i don't think everyone would
love that you got that right but it
could be fun it could be a lot of fun oh
yeah because like in falcon winter
soldier the power broker was always this
mysterious force and we never really got
a whole look of like how she actually
moves right you know what she actually
does beyond you know killing people that
betray her i think i'll have to up steal
yours too because it doesn't make sense
for for her to play a role here but i
mean we would love it to be vinnie d
baby come on come on
you don't have to explain everything
about netflix and how it works you don't
have to explain it just bring it back yo
even if the power broker was working
with kingpin which would make a lot of
sense i would love that too let's make
it happen both of them together it
ship it let's go here we go
i ship it together vanessa we don't need
vanessa
vanessa oh hello hello hello hello
sharon do you like plain white paintings
the only thing i need you to do is like
plain white paintings that's it she's
like i love plain white men so
so i just played
i'm sorry steve no it's true
steve
as milk toast as they come but before we
continue there is a new latest obsession
shirt over at new rockstarsmerch.com
inspired by hawkeye it's a really cool
design and there's a limited supply so
grab one really quick before you'll need
you know an exploding arrow to get your
hands on one and they recently had the
vault open for their black friday event
and maybe that vault is even still open
could it be could it still be open is it
possible we'll find out who knows
you never know where we're gonna shut
the vault for good but either way find
that shirt and tons of other great merch
options inspired by loki spider-man and
other cool nerdy ass properties over at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's the best
one-stop shop for all your nerd needs
like this shirt i love this shirt so
much and before we dive into our bite
size questions next some words from the
people that help us bring big question
to you people like notion with so much
work being done remotely including here
at new rockstars it's never been more
important to make your team work fast
and stay aligned and you need one hub
where everyone can share work manage
projects and collaborate with clarity
notion provides one central and
customizable workspace that can be
tailored to fit any team and bring all
teams together to get more done and move
faster notion is an all-in-one team
collaboration tool that combines
note-taking document sharing wikis
project management and much much more
into one space that's simple powerful
and beautifully designed and plus notion
has a worldwide network of millions of
users creating templates tutorials and
new inspiration and the product is
getting better all the time and you'll
always have the support that you need so
find out how notion may be the missing
piece that your team needs to grow and
get more done learn more and get started
for free at notion.so
and you can check it out on your own and
invite as many folks as you want to see
how it works and take the first step
towards getting an organized happy team
today again at notion.so
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements you're not alone the weight
of debt can be like a celestial standing
on your back and boy are they big and
certainly heavy upstart can help lift
that weight and get you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is the fast
and easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online pay off credit
cards consolidate high interest debt or
fund personal expenses with upstart over
a million people have used upstart to
get one fixed monthly payment with a
clear payoff date upstart considers
factors other than credit score like
your income current employment and
credit history to find you a smarter
rate for your loan you can check your
rate without impacting your credit score
for loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars receive funds as fast
as one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com big question that's
upstart.com bigquestion don't forget to
use our url to let them know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com bigquestion
while you're shopping for holiday gifts
you don't want to forget about folks
purposely on your naughty list
you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about that bedroom naughty
but that's where our friends at adam and
eve can help and they've got all the
naughty gifts that you and your partner
are going to love they have 24 7
customer service and 90 day no hassle
returns they ship in discrete packaging
that no one is going to be silently
judging at your doorstep and adam and
eve is celebrating their 50th
anniversary this year and 20 of their
profit goes to fight the spread of hiv
around the world we've all heard about
supply chain issues and delivery issues
every day on the news so don't wait on
your adam and eve order shop now and
shop early in a hurry while supplies
last go to adamandeve.com and use code
question to get 50 off one item plus
free shipping in the us and canada and
some exclusions to apply again that is
adamandeve.com and use the code question
to get 50 off one item plus free
shipping in the us and canada adam and
eve it's time to get it on now it is
time for our bite size questions brandon
are you ready
i'm ready for these tasty bite-sized
questions
almost like a uh what do you call those
things a uh and a moose bouche oh okay
fancy
this thing that they make on the
microwave the children for the children
an hors d'oeuvre no the the the a
toastino's pizza roll yeah the pizza
rolls there we go the tostinos i prefer
the bagel bite
pizza on a bagel pizza
well brandon how does captain america's
shield stick to his back and this is
from king variant on twitter i know you
came variant thank you for being an
amazing supporter of the channel well
well well king variant uh this is a a
very popular question regarding cap's
sometimes magical acting shield right
after you know the the question how the
hell does this thing just bounce right
back to him uh it's science i can't
explain it it's science spider-man said
it best that thing does not obey the
laws of physics at all no it doesn't it
don't it don't but how does that iconic
shield just like so cleanly and securely
just stick to steve's back or whoever's
wearing it just pops right on there
right
we've seen multiple characters from
steve rogers and most recently sam
wilson all wear the shield on their back
with ease but how are they doing it how
are they doing it the simplest answer is
probably magnets
dude you know magnets how do they work
you know in the age of ultron we saw how
cap used magnets to make the shield
stick to his forearm though he appears
to only ever use that for our magnet
thing in age of ultron like it never
really came back like every other time
we see inside the shield he's like using
the straps you know
yeah and getting that iconic like strap
tightening right before he takes on the
mad titan it wouldn't be effective
cinematically if it was just like
magnets like we want to see that
right
n he's ready
so it feels like you know cap tried out
the magnets for that one fight and was
like tony i appreciate this this is
really nice but it's not my it's not my
too much technology man i can't deal
with this technology
i like my uh belt straps from the uh
yeah i like the i like to feel the
leather on my skin um
that doesn't mean he's not using a
magnet to hold it the shield on his back
um but given like the kind of concave
nature of the shield right if the
magnet's like in that little center
piece of his harness it would have to be
like a really strong magnet to hold the
shield there without directly connecting
to it right so
we should also note that in the comics
vibranium is not magnetic and i know we
see cap uses electromagnets to hold the
shield on his arm so it's possible that
they added some like ferrous metal to
the inside of the shield to make the
those magnet things work but again also
vibranium in
the mcu might be magnetic i don't know
it's tough to say they have never really
said what it's like properties are but
we have seen that magnets have worked
with the shield in some capacity whether
they're attracted to the vibranium or
they're attracted to something they
added to the shield they can work so the
other way that the shield could stick to
the back is just kind of like a simple
hook that like holds the arm strap or
something like there could be like a
little hook that pops out uh we don't
get too many looks at like captain
america's back with the shoulder harness
without the shield but you know there
have been like pictures of the costume
and stuff online and it's like a small
peg that was like kind of on the inside
of the shield that you know some some
like cosplayers have done that they've
used like a little peg if you're a dude
who carries the shield around you
practice like sliding it on there or
like a little hook that pops out and
catches the like leather straps that
could all work hey if we if there's
anything that we know about steve rogers
that steve rogers loves him a good peg
um
i'll be here all week everyone
that was good that was too good i did it
that was great and then sam you know
wilson's like captain america wing suit
it was made by wakandan so
it has all sorts of magical properties
who knows they knew the shield had to go
back there it could have like a little
nanotech holder that pops out you know
it could have some sort of like
vibranium activated thing i don't know
like sam's sam's suit the answer is
magic uh but for bucky and steve i think
it's just i think it's just like a
little physical hook that catches it
yeah it's too easy and it it slides on
and it looks great it's a movie folks i
don't know what you want but there's
something there holding it i actually
talked to kevin feige the other day and
he said that there's actually a tiny
tinker bell nice boots tinker bell
oh a tiny little tinker bell huh she's
just holding it up with all the
restraints he's like
just like hurry up and take it again
and that's why everyone has to clap
around captain america so she doesn't
die exactly sometimes you got to clap
back at captain america bring back the
[Applause]
civil war all right our second bite size
question of the day is brandon who is
the most powerful mutant and this is
from anna the intern at our offices
thank you hannah she's wonderful if you
guys don't know anna just follow her on
twitter yes please she's wonderful she's
a wonderful person wonderful person and
a great question it really takes me back
to my days on the playground in middle
school arguing amongst my friends who
the most powerful mutant was i was
always always always on team magneto
especially when you got them juiced up
on that kick you know that oh that's
getting drug
he gets all
jacked on kick he's ripping all the
pipes out of the ground he's taking over
new york city hell yeah magneto but who
is the most powerful mutant mt you know
people always say like professor x gene
grey apocalypse i mean he's pretty
powerful ever heard of him took over
egypt there's so many to choose from but
thankfully marvel comics has provided an
answer on just who the most powerful
mutant is okay from history of the
marvel universe number three back in
2019 we learn that franklin richards the
son of reed richards and sue storm is
the most powerful mutant full stop boom
there's your answer and this factoid if
you don't believe it take it up with the
guy who said it okay it comes directly
from the mouth of galactus himself okay
oh my god so that's like gospel truth
galactus knows a thing or two about
power okay he tells franklin that he's
the most powerful mutant ever born and
that as galactus is consuming worlds so
do you build
franklin richards is of course he's like
extremely powerful because his parents
read and sue they got bombarded by like
cosmic radiation they're not mutants
their dna got altered by that cosmic
power so it resulted in franklin's dna
being affected and so he was born a
mutant and if you didn't know agatha
harkness was his nanny and protector
when he was a little baby boy ever heard
of her she's pretty powerful too
uh like there was this whole crazy story
i think and this was like back in the
60s i believe reed has to go to the
negative zone to get this like powerful
control rod because sue's freaking out
when she's pregnant it was all this
crazy stuff the baby gets born
i need to control rod because my wife is
just my life right now yeah cravings i
don't know she's disappearing things are
happening with her blood i don't know he
gets born he's immune and like his power
is manifested at like a super early age
whereas like most mutants you know it
doesn't happen until puberty right like
franklin right right out the gate he's
like a powerful mutant what can you do
that's so powerful you might be asking
well i'm glad you asked he has the power
to like warp reality as he sees fit and
he even has the power to like create
entire universes he's basically like the
scarlet witch but he's like a little
more in control of it right from the
get-go um and even like celestials have
recognized that franklin has a power
that rivals their own celestials we're
like this boy is powerful okay so yeah
no reason to have any more playground
arguments franklin richards he's the
boss he reigns supreme he's the most
powerful mutant watch out for him
because he's coming for you he's coming
for you yourself you we're talking about
you he's gonna
i don't know what you did to have me for
franklin richards but he's coming this
is 100 true because franklin richards is
literally one of the most powerful
characters that marvel has ever made now
it is time for my favorite part of the
show brandon it is time for the box of
scraps
boxers
the box of scraps scraps boxes grimes
alfred get the box of scraps
i need you albert i forgot the fast
scraps at home i forgot to put it in the
batmobile what good is this doing all
those push-ups if you can't even lift a
box of scraps
but brandon if you were the head of the
most powerful small-time crime syndicate
in new york city what would your game be
called and how would you make money
interesting so we're talking like small
petty crimes we're the the king of petty
crimes
yeah um hmm what am i okay here's what
my gang do
dude right here what my game is gonna be
doing okay we're called the cereal boys
okay
okay we go into grocery stores
maybe in the cover of night maybe in
broad daylight who knows and we go to
the cereal aisle and we
cut open cereal boxes from the bottom
and we take the toys out of the cereal
boxes all the surprises all the little
goodies
we're taking them right out of the lucky
charms out of the kicks out of the
tricks out of the fruity pebbles we're
taking all the toys no bigger troll
those toys we sell those toys on the
black market okay we're the cereal boys
you better watch out you better not mess
with us or you'll wind up with a toy in
your throat dead oh my god
but we you know that's what we do i like
to think that sunny birch is dealing
with cereal boys like hey where's our
cereal of toys what's going on here boys
we sell all those toys and we use that
money to buy illegal black market
technology it's a perfect business model
oh my god that's a good one i love it i
love it you know what i would do i would
hire a bunch of i would hire the
children to go around
all the orphans of the city and be like
hello orphan children here's what we're
going to do i'm only doing this because
there's a dc villain called by the name
of the penny plunderer okay so i what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna have all these
kids go around finding pennies and then
bring me the pennies and then we'll use
the pennies to build up a crying empire
and then use of the pennies that we do
find to throw them at people
and and it will have a penny gang just
based off the penny plunderer from dc
comics and it will only be orphans
because they don't have parents and i'll
be the they're orphans they're petty
parents i think this is the plot of
oliver twist i never write it but i'm
pretty scared
i'll be the petty father petty father mt
petty parents i mean you should be the
penny pinchers right you should be the
pennies yes oh my god perfect see now
you're you're running marketing now
penny pictures
nice but that is it for this episode of
big question i of course want to thank
off-screen producer brandon for joining
me this episode please follow him at
grindenberric on twitter he's a
wonderful man you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird and of
course follow the rockstars here on
youtube and on all other social media
platforms and of course make sure to hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
conversation our new rockstars discord
server is now open to the public and
we've made some channels available to
non-patrons so you can be part of the
broader community of new rockstars fans
on discord if you're over 18 and
interested and please be sure to be over
18 in case you can't be under 18. um
search for the new rockstars discord
server and join the conversation thank
you guys again for watching and we'll
see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you